Ian Bremmer Eurasia Group president and
CBS News senior global affairs
contributor is with us good morning
this g20 summit going on in Argentina is
a big deal a lot of potential meetings
that have now been scaled back first
let's address the president Trump's
meeting potential meeting that was going
to be with Vladimir Putin I heard from
the White House well that's up in the
air and then Trump comes out and says
I've cancelled the whole meeting yeah
was it really about what Russia has done
in Kiev worried about what's happening
at home no it's clearly what happening
at home is unprecedented in terms of
level of domestic crisis that Trump is
feeling not only cancelling that but
also cancelling the formal meetings with
the South Korean and Turkish leaders
both which we're gonna go quite well now
they're just informal pull asides he
clearly needs the time to discuss
something else that's more urgent we all
know what that is isn't that playing
into Russia's hands why not announcer
earlier this week I'm not gonna meet
with with Russian President Vladimir
Putin after what they've done in Kent
because it wasn't about Ukraine if it
was just about Ukraine they can have
that meeting he can be and deliver a
message around it and Putin was one of
the people he's comfortable people he
hates all of these summits because he
feels ganged up on but this summit was
set up better for Trump not only does he
have a decent personal relationship with
Putin but also erdowan also Mohammed bin
Salman you now have the Italians you
have the Brazilians that have elected to
leaders they're in favor of Trump style
policy he's got a bit of a team in place
it's not like last year's g20 where
Putin was the only guy you want to talk
to so he should have felt good coming in
but the news back home is driving him
insane by the way this could be
interpreted as an embarrassment for
Vladimir Putin right Russia had
acknowledged that this meeting would be
taking place at a time in place at at
least two hours we can be put aside at
9:30 a.m. tomorrow so we'll see what
happens with that if in fact they do end
up meeting just as a pull aside but
other meetings scheduled as well
potentially a trade deal maybe with
Chinese President Xi Jinping yeah we
just had of course the signature between
the Canadians the Americans and the
Mexicans of this new naff to the US
Mexico Canada agreement that is a win
for president Trump and then the biggest
meeting of the entire summit maybe more
important that summit itself is
President Trump and President Xi Jinping
meeting on Saturday night both a private
bilateral and then a dinner and this
meeting has been overwhelmingly
prebate to not be a disaster the Chinese
really want to have something that
least looks like a statement of
principles kind of like what you had
between the North Koreans and the
Americans so that they can say let's
take a step back let's take a breath we
know we don't love each other but we
want some time to ensure this doesn't
become a full-blown trade war that is
possible and the Chinese want it but it
is also possible that Trump says you
know what I'm going to go ahead with
these new tariffs coming in on January
1st the markets not gonna like that
there's a lot to play for I feel quite
confident that this meeting won't go
badly but it's not clear the Chinese are
gonna get what they want what's the
likelihood that we see the president
impose new tariffs make sure uh you know
I think it's a little less than 50/50
the fact that Peter Navarro the
hardliner has been reinserted into this
meeting he had been taken off is a bad
sign the fact that the Secretary of
Treasury minuchin is the one that's been
driving the bilateral relationship is a
good sign but let's keep in mind the one
thing that's really interesting
Trump beats on China all the time he
never goes after she shouldn't paying
personally at his meeting in Mara Lago
that they had that was the best meeting
of his entire first year in terms of
foreign policy
I see Trump as the kind of guy that when
he gets in the room with the big guy he
wants to show that he can pull a rabbit
out the Hat so I'm I tend to be a little
bit more optimistic about this than I
think most are like says he and Xi
Jinping really get along anyway thank
you so much yes